so what do you think about the whole
uh culture of
um I don't know if better turns but woke
activism so sort of activism
which in some contexts is a powerful and
important thing but infiltrating
companies I'll answer this in the
context of Renee Gerard so like he says
that people tend to copy each other
and then when they're copying each other
they're really what they're fighting
what they're doing is they're fighting
over some scarce resource
and then you find a way to organize
against you know the group of you
against a person or a thing that you
think is the actual cause of all of this
conflict and you try to expel them
the thing that wokeism doesn't
understand
is that unless that person is truly to
blame the cycle just continues
and you know that was a that was a
framework that he developed that you
know he's really conclusively proven to
be true and it's observable in humanity
in life
so these movements I think the extreme
left and the extreme right
are trying to interpret away
to allow people to compete for some
scarce resource
but I also think that in all of that
what they don't realize is that they can
scapegoat whoever they want but it's not
going to work because the the Bull Work
of people in the middle realize that
it's just not true
yeah they realize but they're still
because in leadership positions there's
still momentum and they still scapegoat
and they continue
and it seems to hurt the actual ability
In fairness though if you had to graph
the effectiveness of that function it's
decaying rapidly it's the least
effective it's ever been you're
absolutely right being canceled five
years ago was a huge deal
today I think it was Jordan Peterson on
your podcast he said I've been canceled
and it was amazing he said 38 times or
40 he said some number which was a
ginormous number a that he kept account
of it and B was able to classify it yeah
I'm like what classifier is going on in
his mind where he's like Ah that's an
attempt to cancel me but this one is not
but my point is
was clearly not working
and so the guy is still there and the
guy is you know putting his view out
into the world
um and so it's not what not to judge
whether what he says is right or wrong
it's just to observe that this mechanism
mechanism of action is now weakened but
it's weakened because it's not the thing
that people think is really to blame